this steak sandwich is one of the best
things you'll ever have start off by
firing up the charcoal then we're going
to season our steak with salt pepper
garlic smoke the steak at 225 for 20
minutes then we're gonna slice up our
onions and mushrooms sear the steak over
direct heat until it reaches the
internal Tempo 135 fry up the mushrooms
and onions with flour thyme
Worcestershire red wine heavy whipping
cream let it thicken and set it aside
slice and toast your ciabatta bread then
we're going to slice into this perfectly
cooked steak assemble with our mushroom
cream sauce steak swiss cheese more
cream sauce and Dive Right In This was
so good